you're one of the funniest people out  there  you were for a very long time putting  out some of the funniest content and now  it's just like like scary  it's for balance what what happened  is it weird that I think it's funny  is it I you know I I think the comedy  part of my career is still going I think  it's still active wow and part of that  you know part I I talk about it as sort  of like the difference between comedy  and horror is the music  and it really does it does feel like  that you know when when we uh sorry I'm  sorry  now I'm picturing the scene in get out  with with the guys running like you know  he's running at the camera and he's like  head on but now I'm picturing like  just like Benny Hill and it's funny it's  funny and it's very funny  and I could have done I was at the  finish line with that film I could have  gone either way it would have been a  very different film